so today we're on the roof of the
physics building at the University of
Nottingham in a rare moment of English
sunshine to talk about some of the light
that comes from the Sun so this is one
of our to teaching telescopes that we
have here at the University of
Nottingham but this is a special one
this is a solar telescope so it's
designed to look at the Sun not your
usual telescope where you take it out at
night it's actually a daytime telescope
I mean yeah come on in well everyone
knows that you never look at the Sun
with your naked eye and you especially
never ever look at the Sun through
binoculars or a telescope the one
exception being this kind of telescope
which is a solar telescope this
telescope allows only a certain
wavelength of light from the Sun through
and this is a wavelength of light I want
to talk about today this is hydrogen
alpha what we call h alpha in astronomy
and this is a very specific way of
length of light it's 650 6.28 nanometers
and it marks the transition of electrons
around the hydrogen atom from the third
level to the second level so if you
think of the atom as this classic of
Borat and we've got nucleus and you've
got electrons orbiting at fixed energy
levels around that nucleus transitions
from electron falling from the third
level to the second level when they do
that they release an amount of energy
and that energy radiates at that
specific wavelength and we call that
hydrogen-alpha it's the first level in
the Balmer series which is all of these
different transitions that come down to
that N equals 2 energy level well if
we're thinking about the Sun in
particular if we look at the Sun using
an H alpha enabled telescope it allows
us to peer into what's called the
chromosphere literally the color sphere
of the Sun which is one of the levels of
the atmosphere of the Sun by narrowing
down the light that you allow through
your telescope till just this one
interesting transition is seen that's
where you get the beautiful detailed
pictures of the Sun with the surface
features the sunspots the
big prominences and filaments and you
wouldn't normally see that because the
detail is just washed out I'll give you
an example so in astronomy we often put
filters in our telescope something like
this that will restrict the wavelength
range of the light that's allowed in
this is a very crude filter it's really
only allowing sort of reddish light in
but we want even more specific light to
come through we want not just a weight
range of say a hundred nanometers to
come through we want say only one
nanometer around that specific
wavelength to get down to our telescope
so we can see that detail as it's set up
now we can't look through this telescope
because it's got a camera on the end of
it unfortunately when we turned it on
today that camera wasn't working yeah it
is possible to fit an eyepiece to it and
you can look through it and the only
reason again for safety's sake that you
can look through it is because it's got
really heavy-duty filters in it this is
a blocking filter that reduces the
amount of light and the wavelength of
light otherwise you would you would fry
your optics and you would fry your eye
if you looked through an eyepiece on it
this camera over here is connected to
this computer that does all the image
acquisition this isn't a lot of picture
this is not unfortunate live picture
because the cameras not working today
but this is a picture that's been taken
previously with this telescope what you
can see is the chromosphere of the Sun
and you can see some of the details some
of these light filamentary features
these dark sunspots and this beautiful
big loopy prominence as well as some
more fuzz around it around the side all
I can see is a smiley face a smaller ah
I'm sorry it's like the Sun smiling at
me it is like the Sun smiling at you but
the Sun is just one star and I'm not a
solar astronomer when I deal with stars
they're in units of hundreds of billions
and they're wrapped up in packages
called galaxies so here at Nottingham
along with some colleagues of mine we
have used another telescope a much
bigger telescope a 10 meter diameter
telescope on the island of la palma
called the grand telescope Jochen arias
or
kamme we were awarded 90 hours on the
telescope spread out over a period of a
few years do a very large project with
an instrument on the telescope that
works in a way not unlike the filter on
this telescope works this is not
entirely correct analogy because the
telescope is different this is a
refracting telescope it has a lens and
not a mirror but it has a very special
thing inside here which is called a
fabry-perot etholon it's an interference
filter and its job is to vastly restrict
the amount of light coming in to isolate
exactly the wavelengths that we want so
it turns our wide filter into a filter
with a width of just a nanometer or so
and it's tunable so it's got two little
plates inside a reflecting material and
the light comes in bounces off those
plates back and forth and forms
interferences so constructive
interference where the wavelength match
the phase of the wave length of light
matches and builds up the amplitude and
destructive interference where it
cancels out and that allows only
specific wavelengths of light to get
through this system the blocking filter
takes care of the rest and out the other
end comes only our wavelength of
interest H alpha H alpha in extra
galactic or galactic terms tells us
where stars are forming in the galaxies
and that's one of the really fundamental
characteristics that we're really
interested in in understanding how
galaxies form and how they evolve so if
you think of something like the Orion
Nebula the big star forming region in
the belt near the belt of Orion
that's an emission nebula so that's lots
of gas and inside that stars are forming
and the stars that form are really hot
really young stars they're radiating
lots of UV light ultraviolet light there
ionizing all of this gas around it so
they're stripping the electrons from
their hydrogen atom and then when those
electrons fall back down they ran out
radiation including this really
important hydrogen alpha so hydrogen
alpha when we look at a galaxy is a
marker for where stars are forming
and we measure that in terms of solar
masses per year we measure a star
formation rate of a galaxy and some
galaxies are forming stars in a much
more vigorous rate than others and part
of our job is to figure out why that is
why that why not just a lot from the
stars themselves well we do that as well
that's another so we try to approach
this problem from as many angles as we
can and directly measuring the
ultraviolet light from young stars is
one direct measure of the star formation
rate and we do that using ultraviolet
telescopes but to be very effective we
have to get above the earth the
atmosphere to do that because thankfully
the atmosphere shields most of that UV
radiation from from getting down to us
so that's one tool in our toolbox
h-alpha is very handy it's in the
visible regime which is you know where
our optical telescopes you know our
flagship telescopes are built to operate
and it gives us another direct
measurement it's not the whole story
because some of that star formation can
be hidden it can be enshrouded in by
dust and in that case the UV photons
don't make it out they get the heat up
the dust but we can still see that
because you can't hide that radiation it
just comes out reradiating at longer
wavelengths say in the submillimetre and
you need another different kind of
telescope to look look at that but you
put all these measurements together and
you get a complete census of the star
formation in a galaxy
and then when we put them all together
we get this cube that lets us do some
really interesting things because it not
only gives us a picture of a galaxy but
it gives us a go to hoe only I can get
it into the middle of that stack and you
find where the peak of that spectrum is
that's what that galaxy looks like in
each alpha